allez c'est parti pour le match entre
communautés france pologne
on est chaud et on va lui jouer une
grotte maître fide ont fait une robe
aller en cart plus de ont fait la grotte
l'esprit de la drogue est avec nous ses
dessins pour fou j'ai 2 bon je prends
des gros risques quand les mecs je
prends des gros risque que les mecs
valoir que vous assuriez derrière il
faut qu'on le gagne ce match à tout prix
il fait ses cinq attention non je vais
faire c'est 4 1 ça m'intéresse pas du
tout en fait jusqu'avant purgé quatre
qui est bien placé allez c'est bon c'est
bon il faut que chaque fois qu'on marque
des points aujourd'hui va falloir
marquer les trois points à faire comme
dit ou trois points dans ce fantastique
quand on joue on jouit de benoni avec le
pion g4 attention c'est quand même très
très dangereux comme ouverture
d'ailleurs ça retire ma vie en sueur
devant cette benoni lui-même faire b4 et
faire un genre de gandhi venco avec le
pion le purger quatre il fait j'ai ici
c'est là l'esprit de la grotte h4 dégage
pas aux sangsues il se rangeait 4h 4 ha
bah on va mettre un pur angers 5-1 voilà
un honteux montant ferme ton cavaliers
dégage donc à une sortira pas un f6
honte à couper les oreilles on a
entraîné des pions sur les ailes et
maintenant on est très très heureux de
ça hollande est très très heureux dans
les mecs à l'entamé de carrière h3
dégage
parce qu'un trait conquet h 3 portes
avec hayon d2 dégage quand même on va se
fixer un camaïeu 4 on est très heureux
allez on était en 1 4 on est très très
heureux de notre cavalier cif f5
comprendra et on verra
il fait b 6 bon match 3 ans il dit on
veut faire kiev quartier des cinglés
entendu fantastique un mas parti c'est
génial ça n'a ni queue ni tête ça ne
veut rien dire c'est complètement débile
j'adore je suis tellement heureux de ma
partie c'est tellement une partie d'
idiot qu'un milliard ifab c'est une
partie méga rituel on va faire bouger
cinq affaires au sein affaires fou g3
c'est extraordinaire là cette farce il
c'est extraordinaire comme ça j'ai
réussi à placer mon fou en g3 à y mettre
le caillou f5 cette pénible ça
je faire tf6 quand même je vais changer
remettre le fourrage de ou pas
d'ailleurs
c'est tellement du high level ce que je
suis en train de faire je vais faire tg5
je vais me laisser changeant h hinges
l'apprendre en g3 et je vais vouloir
jouer avec food et 5
c'est extraordinaire
je suis tellement au dessus du game
quand je joue comme ça j'ai l'impression
d'être tellement au dessus du game quand
je joue comme ça fois c'est tellement
c'est tellement lâche ancla pour lui la
chambre que là bas il s'en prendre
partout quoi elle serait de battre m
fille dans 15 + 3 avec la grotte prem ce
serait beau quoi nouveau maître fide en
sueur en sueur absolue quoi on mène déjà
1-0 les mecs on en a marqué le premier
point a et un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour kiwi parce qu'il
vient de battre 764 kiwi parce qu'ils
oui parce qu'ils y passent là au kouilou
kiwi passe la poussière trépasse
il est tellement sueur
c'est cool qu'on mène 1-0 très cool très
cool aux faucons et cartonne les mecs
tram c'est génial que mon adversaire en
sueur devant la grotte la pologne en
sueur devant la grotte je passe bientôt
marquer des points mais si on l'est
cartonne derrière c'est bon derrière
c'est vrai qu'on peut on peut réussir à
mettre un petit 10 0 et puis devant on
tiendra devant on a un peu moins fort
mais on tiendra les mecs un peu
inquiétez pas je veux reprendre 2e
c'était dans mon idée de base ou même
pas réfléchir je ne réfléchis pas à quoi
ça je me libère les cases the cat
éventuellement pour le cavalier je lui
faire d'alger quatre grands rock tour
atteinte
formidable c'est extraordinaire nous
lisons de dame écrivait dans le chat un
peu ce qui se passe dans vos parties en
les mecs on veut savoir on veut savoir
où on en est un ressort qui gagne qui ne
gagnent pas prêt peut-être faire kébé
c'est pour faire payer d ici c'est
d'amener cette alors ça je vais vous
dire ça m'inquiète mais alors pas du
tout je veux lui faire d'alger car j'ai
continué à jouer thème pour écouter
damas cinq échecs j'ai fait 3e deux
dames bk je vais faire tout rachat dame
prend b2 wife 3 ok ça j'ai envie de
faire grand roque et tourache un perso
c'est ce que je vais faire
j'aurais aussi pu faire ou f2 mais j'ai
envie de faire un gros ketura chain et
je fais retour à shatura fuite
qui fait m17 maintenant ouais j'ai pas
tout rage suite et j'ai pas tout de
suite parce qu'il y aura pas match
aïe aïe aïe alors si je fais en h cup
fait dans le machin aïe aïe aïe c'est
dommage est ce que
je laisse pas gagner en force
quand même très envie d'essayer de
gagner en force d'âme à cana machin
j'étais je vais pas réussir à mater je
suis obligé de rentrer dans l'affinage
croira joua pas rien d'autre et prend
dans ses 4 il ya 3 2 pour nous ouais
pourquoi prendre un coup on a perdu on
perd un peu mais on perd un peu des
points à certains endroits au retour des
8 tu veux pas faire tout re 1 et sur
wade si ce qui est le quatrième français
s'inquiétait tour ici ok il défend tout
pas mal joué de sa part
c'est une option b 3
histoire de couvrir le pion c4 qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire tourache un tour h7
maintenant j'essaie de faire tout
racisme je fais retour là c'est pas
grave que j'essaie de faire tout rage
7,2 c'est rien c'est rien ça va pas bien
loin et on veut tous rage sept
et on veut tour h7 hockey mètres la tour
h7
bon il continue à défendre ou kg 5
accueille des six cavaliers eu six tours
c8 et ça continue à défendre et je vais
peut-être faire des quatre abb ça allait
on va faire des quatre il va apprendre à
faire ces 5
ça a commencé à prendre forme
alors faire qui est des 8es on pourra
peut-être joué avec ses six échecs à un
moment donné va peut-être monter droit
et on pourra peut-être loïc c6 hockey du
coup il prend là on va prendre
il va faire ça ok il trouve du con tre
jeu assez bien joué ça de sa part
ah j'ai raté ça ça c'est bien joué de sa
part
j'ai raté ça j'ai peut-être perdre même
assez pas de bol assez idiot
j'ai raté ce contre je sais bien joué ça
j'ai raté c'est dommage parce que
j'aurais pas fait ces cinq j'aurais fait
rouaroua monte j'ai joué trop vite on a
joué trop vite j'ai envie de m'amuser en
même temps c'est dommage gratuit écoeuré
je suis écoeuré
qui est rare en déça et gk de saké
france
je suis mal de partout ouais c'est
vraiment pas d'où je suis planté ouais
je me suis planté là pourtant
stratégiquement j'ai tellement dominé
cette partie
c'est bête
j'aurais dû faire kg 5 machin qui
réussissent bkc cinq ans tordre l'ice a
gagné m'ont écouté ses bêtes
c'est vrai que j'aurais pu le battre
avec la grave on puisse un maître fille
dont j'aurai battu avec la grave ça
aurait été sympa quoi moins cher qui est
des trois g4
mais ça c'est juste mauvais quoi samsung
2-0 pour qu'il y passe assez bien on
mène que 7 4 1 et moi j'ai déconné
pourtant j'étais bien avec ma drogue
ça m'agace ça m'agace ça m'agace ça
m'agace complètement oublié ce truc là
bas les emmène 9,4 on est bien sur mac
nuls quoi
phase 3 4 que juste en décalé ses cinq
courts f4 qui est 17 heures point f7 et
machins et mais bon normalement lille va
jouer quatre cahiers prend bay 4 3 ou 5
essais 6 3 prend qui est des cathédrales
g5 et en fait ça c'est très chiant mais
il faut qu'ils le voient encore c'est
pas si simple avoir aisément dominé
toute la partie je me prends ce truc à
la fin ben quoi tellement bête
incroyable bon ça arrive c'est la vie
alan mais non 5
on m'annonce un qu'on nous dit bon c'est
bon d'en face on va aller ça c'est pas
grave en fait je peux perdre face on va
aller défoncer ont cinq-six ont continué
à marquer de partout derrière wayne dans
sa vallée on va les écraser je pense à
tâtons ci soit au pied on perd un peu
devant mais derrière on va les écraser
juste je sais pas quoi il réfléchit
honnêtement parce que le truc que j'ai
dit sky méga logique après fois que
j'essaye de faire ni avec le cavalier
cela est possible de faire nul mais mais
j'aime pas trop ce genre de finale vous
me flaud qui nous rapporte un point très
simple qui a fait 13,6 en réalité 14,5
en effet pas dans les cartons
honnêtement il ya pas match honnêtement
c'est juste un massacre autant on a
perdu contre les portugais les espagnols
autant là contre les polonais c'est
massacre à la tronçonneuse arias il ya
même pas match honnêtement c'est
quasiment fin c'est trop facile en fait
alors il veut jouer comme ça
j'ai envie de dire pourquoi pas cavalier
à 6 qu'est ce qu'il fait il repart en
apparent des six peut-être et du coup je
peux revenir en ville car être bon allez
j'ai envie de jouer vite là j'en ai
marre ouais mais je joue mal mais mon
truc c'est que je sais c'est pas failli
ce qui me plaisent en fait c'est pas des
carences qui me font qui fait qu'en cd
partie sérieuse pourquoi pas mais sinon
sinon c'est trop long quoi pour des
parties amicales c'est trop long 15 + 2
c'est trop long d'ailleurs personne
jouant 15 + 2 c'est trop long sinon
ouais je restais concentré je rêvais
garder ma position gagnante quoi aïe aïe
aïe ça voudra +105 plus trois ans de
plus 1 15 + 5 c'est vraiment nom propre
châssis que c'est marrant parce qu'il ya
un gros enjeu machin et tout quoi faire
un gros enjeu il ya un petit enjeu et
tous ses fans mais en fait sinon je
n'arrive pas mais je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez en le chat n'hésitez pas
à me dire mais sinon j'ai j'ai du mal
quoi j'ai du mal bon alors c'est un peu
trop long c'est pas assez dynamique on
est là on attend des cinq minutes
surtout quand tu stream en fait tu en
réalité si je joue ça et que je suis
chez moi en calbute à boire un café à
faire tu vois à écouter de la musique à
fond ou quoi pourquoi pas mais là en
fait en stream c'est un duo est envie
que ça s'arrête a envie d'avoir du
dynamisme qu enfin pour après ils sont
très contents et bollywood
j'aime beaucoup mais elle mais bon après
on est foutu truc je sais jouer vite ça
une partie marrante les mecs un ralenti
tout d'un coup quoi aïe aïe aïe
mais en fait ces pions sont trop
dangereux mon cavalier hors jeu et c'est
foutu ça c'est clairement perdu il va
faire 3 g5 machart marin peut-être g5
des trois ça
roi des huns ce un échec
bon j'ai pas moi j'essaie de jouer vite
en de m'amuser quoi
74 moi j'aime bien les cadences plus
long qu'en revanche un sinon en général
pour jouer des parties 15 + 5 c'est une
course que j'aime bien mais pas quand
c'est des parties amicales et pas quand
juste rime surtout merci brad ac pour le
point 5 pieds 5 pouces 3 ça va en fait
j'aime bien je fais un truc qui est pas
mal pris c'est commencer par tour b18
ouais c'est exactement ce que j'allais
dire ça je pensais bien joué ouais on va
la perdre je suis nulle quoi
je dois jamais la perdre et quand il a
commencé à jouer vite en fait oui bon
bah il veut jouer vite machin et tour et
je me suis excité et j'aurais dû
j'aurais dû savoir qu'il pouvait me la
faire à la sournoise et ralentir quoi
j'aurais dû me douter qu'ils pouvaient
la joie la sournoise assurera b53 des
trois peut-être que ça va encore
warda je suis d'accord qu'un studio 15 +
5 points +0 28 540 plus de ça me va mais
pas en ligne je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi en fête ou en pro de
châssis qu'en fait ça me va aussi
parce que il ya un enjeu en fait et donc
tu as une compétition mais quand tu es
plus là pour le fun et tous espèrent là
c'est trop long concrètement non mais
c'est pas ce n'est pas une raison
c'est pas une raison pour pas cartonné
les machins mais faut qu'il ya un vrai
enjeu sinon c'est dur sur toute l'île
jouer vite au début donc moi le film où
il continue à jouer liste continue à
jouer un tel contrat justement fait il
réfléchit quoi fin il a fait semblant
quoi attaquer vers la cades antoine
après il en faut pour tous les goûts
moi j'aurais plutôt aimé 5 + 0 3 + 3 + 0
1 + 0 par les carences les plus
populaires à l'ancienne un alors si
froid bessin kirwa des trois-rois prend
à 6 et tout reprend des quatre tours 8
et 3 e 2 je bloque l'option eux il va
faire tout re 5 je fais retour ici va
faire tout reprend g5 faire tout reprend
f7 on va troquer les purées ça à faire
nul fait si froid à b5 c'est nul
le truc c'est que je suis en pls mois là
ces nouvelles transmises ou exemple je
suis en semis sous deux angles on sort
lilas y en a qui est en train de rentrer
les chemises ou les anglais et les
frères comment une patrie en fait on va
faire une pause à 20h et puis après on
aura un deuxième ce crime à 21h mais là
on est sur les dents et mal en jeu
contre les polonais alors qu'en fait on
aime 18 18 7 mais c'est moi qui suis mal
contre le polonais mais en fait on s'en
fout mais on gagne le match en train de
les massacrer la sela massacre ada cif
et ours et si je fais quoi je fais
caribe 8
non en fait il ya plein de trucs qui
font que je suis très mal mais bon il
réfléchit des plombes peut-être tours à
huit c'est fort en fait ouais c'est ce
qu'ils jouent derrière mais je voulais
faire qui est b quatre équidés prises çà
tout reprend roi c5 et tours 17
ok j'ai envie de tenter québécois tg
quasi tempo il saura lui dire toi tu
réfléchis longtemps moi je te joue tempo
et sur deux je veux faire roi des deux
aura prend des quatre tours prend est
monté ma tour essayer de faire nul
orange doit mieux jouer les finales que
lui quand même
donc on va prendre une fois en fait si
mayroy ces cinq peut-être que le truc
malin c'est de faire tour 17
et surtout rue 8 3 d1 et surtout rade
roi des huns aussi et / ou droit des
deux bref je pense que faire tour 17
tours 1,8 roi des huns et sarrois d1
je vais réussir à la tenir à nom et
autour des deux échecs à je vais la
perdre ok on peut abandonner a bien joué
j'étais pas loin de là tenir jeudi
réfléchir plus longtemps je n'ai pas
envie c'est à dire que tour 17 c'était
pas mon surf qu'il fallait faire tour 4
et tours 4 c'était probablement nulle
ouais bon je me suis planté écoutez
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave mais
tour quatre tours gaza devait être nulle
c'est dommage j'aurais bien aimé va
apprécier entre les tours 17 tours ici s
est pas de mal que j'ai pas vu qu'il est
le tour des duels on va faire crisser si
ce qui est mauvais on s'y connaît pour
écouter c'est pas grave
à leogane à 11
c'est dommage alors que j'ai cinq et
demi sur six là on fera moins bien mais
tous mach 1 tour 4 ça devait être nulle
tour d un vrai tour qualifié de calculer
en fait dans ma tête mais tour de rodez
1 h 1 e de et si les tours 1,5 je
pouvais troqué de copies ouais ça devait
être nulle assez qu'on a reperdu comme
ça quand même
c'est con d'avoir perdu comme ça
suis idiot mais bon c'est la vie c'est
comme ça
c'est dommage c'est dommage on aimera
toujours et tempo en plus ou moins mais
ça sera pas passé mais je crois pas trop
on fait le dire ce que des bijoux et
tempo et au début je jouais tempo je dis
bon il dit qu'il a commencé un peu long
il veut jouer vite machin est tout et
puis finalement non il réfléchit à fond
quoi rejoue quoi manager région est
parti en glisse et tu aller voir les
autres joueurs que ça a été plus marrant
en fait mais bon il veut réfléchir il va
réfléchir
il est lent par contre impôts c'est la
pls
c'est la catastrophe à la les amis il
réfléchit des plombes contient après ou
de partout montrer notre supériorité
on va continuer à montrer notre
supériorité sur l'adversaire s'il fait
vraiment tout tempo j'ignore
complètement la partie quand je regarde
mon smartphone je suis très heureux en
fait la monf artois ne s'intéressent pas
des gages
t'as qu'à jouer plus vite ouais c'est
génial mais très énervé
pas mais bon je m'en veux quand même un
peu ce que jusqu'à ses seins en fait
c'était bien joué et je me suis pris ce
qu'on aurait pu à la fin à faire ou à
faire retour 17 mai au c'est un peu con
en tous les cas m'emmène 24 13 25 13 de
l'important c'est de gagner de toute
façon si on gagne le match c'est quand
même le plus important mais vous il en
est là pour s'amuser quoi en effet un cg
l'impression de faire un derrick la
tension que c'est le stream en mode
d'eric si t'as pas fait une sieste avant
là on est mal les mecs un impressionnant
qu'à la fin je sais pas
joue puis ça va aussi discuter aussi le
fait des gens qui doyon pro-chasse l'ict
est stressé tu joue moins bien et où
vous voyez quand même la différence
entre quand je suis stressée mais que ça
donne l'impression que je vous reviens
mais en fait je joue mieux mais quand je
suis pas stressé en fait il n'y a aucune
pression il ya beaucoup d'erreurs ça
paraît doigt la différence en fait dès
que tu aies pu sous stress que tu es
machin et tout ça tu fait forcément
beaucoup plus d'erreurs c'est
obligatoire pour pas faire d'erreur faut
être sous pression c'est normal en fait
quand comptes a pas de stress quand t'as
pas de quand t'as pas de rue proposé
nuit à l'est pas soissons il est moins
bien comme ça on va essayer d'aller voir
les autres ce sera plus marrant fatwa +3
plus rigoler quand t'as pas de pression
et tout ça tu fais plus de gaffes
il est non après le score c'est sur les
trois matches mais c'est d'ailleurs
n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire déjà pour
le deuxième match
si vous ne jouez pas et on va aller
claquer dans le deuxième et voilà à 6h
germaine un point et demi bon j'ai la
flemme de calculer on va faire fou le 4
mai je pense foucher je pense qu'il est
plus fort sans voiture et cette finale
est calé on va se donner un défi on va
vouloir finir avec plus de temps qu
détroit on va faire réussisse
si grand qu on va faire fois trois
échecs en une fois on va prendre là on
va rockets s'y prendre la dame ça peut
être différent
sa voix rauque et quand même et on va
faire à 5 à 4 on va essayer avec plus de
temps que ce qu'on a commencé la f5
système à jouer
ça s'était mal joué mon affaire d'un v6
quand même faut qu'on continue à jouer
tempo un faucon tient à jouer vite les
mecs
charles gave a eu les deux la partie
carroll a l'air drôle
ouais mais malheureusement on peut pas
aller voir parole il ralentit cauet
calculs pour voir rester au dessus des
15 minutes nous demande c'est quoi les
liens il ya tous les liens ici ratant
juste faut que je me dépêche
parce que 15 minutes représente 0 pour
nous donc on dirait qu'on avait
virtuellement que 34 secondes
autant dire qu'on doit jouer vite sur
d'armes français sachent faire tout
reprend des cats sur d'armes 4g c5
suroît c3 je fais retour des systèmes
français cette tour des huit et ça
devrait aller
allez
ça peut aller ça peut le faire et ce que
ça le fait ouais ouais faut que ça le
fasse en sa valise a cartonné on a déjà
gagné le premier match c'est sûr il
reste plus plu énormément de partie et
on a cartonné on les a cartonné 1 2 3 4
5 6 à la dernière va gagner là on a fait
des nuls
je suis en train de regarder machin
gauchos qui roissy 3 à l'effet tour des
six on peut continuer à jouer tempo d'un
pro tour des huit on peut continuer à
jouer tempo quoi
ce qui est notre objectif bien
évidemment il est lent qu'est-ce qu'il
est lent à six et cinq étaient plus
forts ou pas possible
au caire
je fâche 5g farge et 6 médailles adam 5
et c'est foutu
il a réussi à défendre le pion des cats
et c'est fichu pour moi on va aller voir
les autres partis mais bon cette cadence
c'est la marque
cette cadence c'est la mort pour moi
mais bref quatre matches assez marrant
je pouvais paraît vraiment taper le pion
qui pouvait pas vraiment taper le pion
je met le pion à 5 je veux l'éviter de
d'obtenir cette case éviter les dames
des huit dames prend à cette fois j'y
suis restée trop 20 15 + 5 oui je suis
d'accord avec toi mac sociaux c'est ce
dont j'ai parlé juste avant ces camps
pros de châssis qu'en fait par exemple
ça va très bien il ya vraiment aucun
souci c'est fun parce qu'il ya un enjeu
en fait quand il n'y a pas d'enjeu
vraiment et tu fais juste un match
amical pour déconner c'est très long en
fait c'est très très long ou alors faut
arrêter de l'argent en jeu tu vas fort
excès s'emballe mais sans enjeu du tout
c'est non clairement la endroit b2 et
dame prend à 5e la finale aller mieux
pour lui
l'objet de sa quête on va à ok si on
fait ça on peut pas
surfer taisei faits d'armes trois dames
b2 doit ici non ça a parlé du tout on
doit prendre il va prendre là
on va faire un échec il va venir là on
va partir par la marque
vva
à faire un échec
envoyez le pion
un genre les deux pions plus loin
on va faire un échec
faire deux échecs
faire trois échecs
qu'est ce que le fait en fait c'est
quand il fait froid à trois jeux faire
dame e cat est d'alger 2 et essayer
d'aller lui taper ça en force mais il
aura dam des huit échecs qui sera chiant
en fait et qui fait qu'on est mal de
partout
ces plans sont trop avancé
montmagny 37 à 19 ans est bon les
massacres 1 en tous les cas on les
massacre les mecs
je réussis à reste à 15 minutes en tout
cas ça c'est la bonne nouvelle mais
c'est dommage que mon roi soit pas un
peu mieux protégés parce que sinon je
pourrais avoir d'amis g2 en force que je
l'aurais pas à cause de dam des trois
chefs d'amd 4 et je préfère trois sets
et je [ __ ] encaissé le pion de machins
et tout mais tellement sueur
on le met en méga sueurs froides et 3 ok
il veut pouvoir avoir
[Musique]
il veut pouvoir couvrir si jamais on va
faire un échec rami a peut-être dame ici
maintenant
mais bon on est mal autant il nous reste
20 secondes
ces trois c'est peut-être pas mal pour
lui en fait tout cas cette impression
ouais on y va et normalement non je
pourrai pour finir etc autant de temps
qu'au début on n'est pas très bien
autant hockey l'atuge fr dame g2 tempo
moi je gagne un peu de temps à même la
rue adam ces deux ça c'est bien joué
ok maintenant il a une marée de pions
qui m'arrive dessus ce qui est quand
même très dangereux
aof
on va faire ça
faire un échec
ouais on va être un peu short
malheureusement malheureusement on a un
peu short
on a 45 secondes maintenant par rapport
à un défi mais les pions sont trop forts
la marée de pion est trop forte
je suis un ami des deux échecs peut-être
plus tôt
ok et si je fais dame prend dans des six
ailleurs à roye 5 ray si je fais d'anne
decis maintenant c'est quand même voilà
j'arrête c'est foutu
ces morts les amis c'est perdu c'est
perdu les amis on n'y peut rien
on n'y peut rien
voilà on est tombé j'abandonne on a
perdu autant on avait 14 cas 57 ans a
perdu autant moment on a perdu les deux
écouter alors dans le joie qu aller on
va essayer de le taper celui-là allez on
va sont là là on va se concentrer
c'est une partie qui m'intéresse plus
donc on va essayer de se concentrer à
fond tous et 4g 4 on va jouer cette
variante safer fouet cinq affaires food
et dont on va faire baver si celle ci
fait que l'union fait aussi ce g4g 6 h 4
et c'est 6 je crois non il a acheté un
fils et saint brice et j'ai quatre
touchés si ce machin ça et oui il ya eu
5 qui calera d'avantagé quatre foulées
ce qui fait ça du coup c'est qui ces six
là dessus je crois ou là c'était
peut-être pas ça parce que la sueur à 3
sur 3 je fais quoi je fais rock ça vous
fait vous et vous b4 et je rebufa c'est
quoi ce délire là
parce qu'en fait si je fais grand robe
et 4 dames b si ce qui a valu à 4 super
la dame
quoique j'ai encore fou prend des quatre
échecs mais sur quoi
moi je vais faire du maroc déjà ça c'est
écrit je crois que je suis très mal en
fait dame b 6
il va y avoir je comprendre qu'il ya 4
qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire sur fouet
c'était quoi le truc sur fouet trois
savoir que je regarde pas ce que j' en
avoir besoin
bon là de façon je faire flamber six
jours d'un v6 qui à quatre francs b4 j'y
crois pas je vais vous prendre b4 direct
je pense qu'il ya juste trois f1 on va
prendre ça tempo four b3 et là tu
voulais faire qui est des amis je suis
short là
qu'est-ce que j'ai mal fait en fait
et parce que j'ai mal fait
je sais pas ce que j'ai mal fait les
mecs ça intéresse ça m'intéresse en fait
en réalité je sais pas où je me suis
planté d'un massacre machin on peut
importe 60 cents fou
[Musique]
voilà le truc c'est qu'il y ait des cinq
plus de qui et prend des kakis et prend
v5 c'est sûr ça machin fou prend il
reprend du fou et c'est complètement
foutu je peux occasion abandonné en fait
partie a pas grand intérêt
ah bon comment on fait pour la jouer
ouais non je me suis planté la position
là étaient horribles en fait y'a pas de
mes mots - j'ai appris quelque chose
écoute c'est pas mal c'est pas plus mal
vaut mieux apprendre quelque chose que
rien apprendre à sa qui a rien à faire
en fait je vais retourner cette tour des
huit mais là c'est foutu mais bon j'ai
appris quelque chose et du couffo 3 n'en
fais pas que j'ai appris c'est que j'ai
oublié un truc et du coup je vais
pouvoir corriger en fait ce que j'ai
oublié
voilà on est complètement foutu un sas
où nettement sas abandonnerait comme
position mais on va la jouer encore un
peu on sait jamais mais du coup la
question mais c'est sûr fouet 3 et ça
c'est bien joué
il prépare des 5
c'était très bien joué ça c'est extra
c'est le coup qu'il faut jouer quoi ces
bons coups ce qu'il a fait mais du coup
sûr fou ou 3 il faut faire peut-être
faire c6 ou des six dames c'est cette
quand même sur fouet trois surfe ou des
deux kivu faire de versace et ses 6 soit
ya ce truc à 3 et c'est pas la première
fois que je me le prends donc c'est
intéressant de c'est intéressant de la
voir jouer cette partie si l on va faire
tout huit tempo c'est intéressant parce
qu'on a réussi à a détecté un problème
et b4
on a réussi à détecter une erreur ça
c'est toujours intéressant c'est
toujours intéressant qu'on va réussir a
détecté une erreur donc là normalement
après la partie va falloir que je que je
rentre que j'aille voir ça sur mon ordi
pour aller checker tout ça une histoire
d'avoir appris quelque chose qui
concentre toi mais franchement j'ai
enfin j'ai vraiment du mal en fait
honnêtement j'ai du mal honnêtement j'ai
du mal à rester concentré
je pense plus ce truc se doit d'une
position perdante est à zéro en jeu tu
vas pas à la rigueur mais ton je perds
tu vois ça me ça me change absolument
rien quoi ça me change absolument rien
et attends je suis planté dans
l'ouverture et ça c'est intéressant par
contre pas que ça arrive dans une arena
ou un truc faut trois essais si si si
c'est sur ces 6 il fait toujours un
effet retour us façon c'est peut-être
g500 premier enfin c'est complètement
foutu la tour prend à 5 qui est très
fort et qui gagnent sur le champ on peut
abandonner direct
qui est tu prends des cinq aussi qui
gagne pour lui il ya tout qui gagne qui
est prendrait cinq peut-être même plus
fort d'ailleurs
mais non le chat que le conseil soit
fait à l'aise mais quel courage et tout
en fait j'en ai vraiment rien à faire un
tu assez fou faut vous compreniez que
c'est enfin ça aucune importance tu as
et 6 avait une importance ou quoi tu me
verras en pls ou quoi là j'en ai je dit
bon je me concentrais pour cette partie
je vis plantées en l'ouverture jouer
trop vite mais à la rigueur tu vois
honnêtement enfin jean néret juin oui
tant pis fin c'est pas grave je m'en
fous totalement d'avoir perdu
donc on va leur faire re 4 en faire même
j'ai quatre ans à faire du groupe
jusqu'à un coquet jouer ça comme ça
faire des quatre ce qu'il fait
famille leur donne des insights s'est
passé juste qu'ils m'ont l'air super
motivé en fait c'est surtout ça la
différence ils ont l'air bien motivés en
fait on y réfléchit à fond ajoute ou
tempo che pas un fan
ils ont juste pas du tout de même
mindset quoi c'est hallucinant fait je
comprends juste pas en fait il ya un
délire que je comprends pas je suis pas
je suis pas dans le délire en fait
je suis pas dans le délire je passais
nan mais c'est même pas aujourd'hui en
fait j'étais patient d'embellir les
autres les autres machins mais je sais
tu meures faire perdre la lame pareil
avec assiste d'ailleurs c'est marrant
parce que ça remarche voilée à [ __ ] en
f2 aussi ouais c'est marrant ça marche
encore voilà on a tenté de jouer tempo
on va continuer dans le même délire je
suis pas dans le délire du je suis pas
rentré dans le délire du tournoi machin
malheureusement j'ai envie de dire voilà
je suis encore foutu cette datation pas
d'équipement pro de chasse ligue aussi
voilà c'est complètement rennes ils
allaient voir b5 et machin c'est
complètement foutu ouais ça avant de
nabeul c'est la même que la partie
d'avant c'est la vigne vraiment désolé
les mecs
j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à me mettre
dedans j'y arrive pas je suis vraiment
désolé les mecs je suis vraiment désolé
mais que j'arrive j'arrive pas à me
j'arrive pas à mettre dedans
il n'y a pas d'excusés après un jeu
n'arrive pas avoir envie en fait pas si
longue si menace gagner ou quoi ça va
aller mais je n'arrive pas avoir envie
de me concentrer à fond et de faire ce
qu'il faut parce que le mec est quand
même fort tu as et un bon grand maître
j'arrive pas à être dans le mood de de
faire ce qu'il faut pour pour la gagner
quoi trop d'émotion hier soir de machin
de trucs et là j'arrive pas du tout a
pas de mental quoi moi je joue bien la
tour prend à trois c'est bien joué bon
après j'avais vu un mais le tour prend à
3 cm un jouet machin et il joue bien il
n'y a pas ça c'est pas remettre en
question c'est pas du tout remettre en
question fait qu'ils jouent mieux points
et tout ça je veux surtout pas surtout
pas l'enlever juste moi je n'arrive pas
à me
l'arrivée monter le roi ça me faire
marrer vous c'est synchro avec quatre
dames ici vois je crois qu'il ya un
matheux forcé pour les noirs si je monte
chaque et g6 donc chargé de faire ça et
ça c'est matt direct alors abandonné on
attend de la prochaine on se fait
dominer avant ce deuxième match phare
que je me chauffe pour le troisième bon
alors ce que font les autres
il faut qu'on gagne il faut qu'on gagne
ce match mais j'ai fait n'importe quoi
non mais c'est abusé en fait que moi
j'ai joué c'est juste abusé c'est juste
allusion à regarder gros baisse c'est
plus marrant alors qu'est ce qui nous
fait gro basque et perdant aussi cette
de best ça devait sa gagne et la
première il joue la deuxième wallop jeu
ses jours avec et des jours sans nom on
verra avec l'arena after à quel point
les jours avec et des jours sans
on verra ce que j'ai juste face et de
même pas mal joué ce que j'ai fait j'ai
même pas joué en fait c'était pire que
mal joué
on verra avec le prochain dame g3 je
suis pas sûr du port de cai h5 de trucs
comme ça on va voir mais on sait qu'ils
attaquent le pion aux 5 et peut-être que
fait rage saint caprais bien times
estate bien jouer dame g3 très l'ajout
évidence être pas bête en fait je dois
faire qui a aidé cette affaire arrive à
faire un show 5
7 h 6 mai après avoir fait re dès qu'il
prend des cinq noms qui jouent tous
tempo aussi à 3,5 et fou prend 1,7 et
c'est fini bon voilà une bonne chose de
faite de doit faire tour g8 fou prend
des huit friis prises la pièce de plus
c'est un massacre
cette baisse qui a massacré bien jouer
vous prend des huit étrangers 3 et puis
on prend des cinq pour c'est une
possibilité il ya peut-être d'autres
manières de gagner il suffit d'un match
4 qui gagne est peut-être encore plus
dans le sens où sont menacés fouet si
c'est sa grinta team dame mais bon le
truc c'est que c'est difficile de pas
rentrer là dedans prévient on prend des
cinq cas une pièce net de + 15 et
peut-être même avec quelques pions je
pense qu à prendre ces six fer fou prend
f7 peut-être fou prend h5
enfin il a tout rasé je pense qu'il
apprendra fiat
c'est pur important ça évite d'avoir un
duo de pions et ça c'est fini
du coup cette baisse qui a gagné 2 0
c'est pas mal à les voir un peu un peu
plus loin on utilise le live or là c'est
sûr fou g3 f4 sa gagne pas de pièce à
cause de trois ça va et le prochain tour
il commença qu'à leur d'ailleurs j'ai
pas le est-ce que j'ai l'horaire quelque
part tu sais pas si j'aurai quelque part
j'ai essayé de regarder ça
alors je trouve pas l'horaire du
prochain mais ça doit être
je crois que ça commence vraiment dans
la dans la dans la foulée quoi
ok bon on a huit points de retard dans
ce petit match mais si on perd patron va
tout jouer sur le dernier ça qui me
passent dans 19 minutes ouais ok ça
commence à 15 commence à 55 ça veut dire
à l'état de faire h 5 kg ici il faut
peut-être faut peut-être rentrer dedans
c'est peut-être faire dan c25 supra f5
choses comme ça on va voir ça peut faire
un truc avec des 5es à oui mais en fait
on est pour les mecs qui allie noir
merde j'ai des couleurs inversées moi je
suis couleurs inversées j'ai tellement
l'habitude on pro-chasse lit que tu es
le côté ton mec du bon côté que je
regarde à l'envers mais peu importe ce
fait les mains peuvent peut-être joué un
truc avec des 5 et affaiblissent les
cases blanches tu fais ed il va te faire
[ __ ] un f5 et tu te fais un peu bouffé
quoi ça peut être une idée on va les
voir grobet ce qu'est qu'est ce que ça
donne n'est pas très bien gros baisse
qu'il allait noir donc ça c'est notre
mec
malgré le drapeau tchèque
mais ce qu'il est bien ou pas
pas l'air d'être très bien un gros
basque avec les noirs cavaliers en d5
pénible après peut-être prendre f3 fer
qui a aidé 4,6 à perdre un pion cif est
prise prise et qu'il est un cas d'école
de la part d'un pion et du coup j'ai
peur qu'il se ferait d'un fou un f4 une
tour en 1 ou même un four 3 d'ailleurs
il est pas très bien on va se faire
défoncer la sur le sur cette cadence on
est mal les mecs ils nous donnent au
fond si l'on me des joueurs forment les
mecs mike cassez qui nous défonce
derrière après les 700 lots défonce 2100
quand on est mal se défoncer par tous
les mecs
on se fait défoncer par tous
bah le match sur retourne contre nous
mêmes mais bon si leurs 700 bat notre
mini nos 1100 aussi qui faisait le
boulot derrière on est malin non 800 se
font marcher dessus quoi alors 800 nous
marchent dessus on va regarder notre
1100 la caisse qui fait contre le 800
voyez quand même pas mal pour le moment
messieurs les faits nul à la première
mais nos autres mais nos autres tient à
des 1200 qui ont perdu la vue en train
de voir ça on se fait marcher dessus
lorsqu'un pays sort il faudra regarder
un peu à il va perdre aussi il va perdre
aussi avec les noirs sont pures et
dominés il ya d'options passé il peut
rien faire roi b2c abandon et on se fait
marcher dessus les mecs et l'abandonné
grobet sq ont peut-être qu'il a un peu
de jeu ça prend des cinq cercles et b4
quand même c'est pas mal et là
maintenant il a peut-être des cinq c4 ok
peut-être gros baisse qui marque mais
l'on sait lance fait marcher dessus
c'est marcher dessus
j'en prends ces captures fonction francs
est d'ambon la la fuye va quoi il va
prendre ces cas prendre b4 prendre des
cats et ça va aller une soirée qui oui
parce j'ai ici c'était 5 fu et 4 elle va
mettre le x e 4 ça va aller l'iphone 4
qui essaient 6 attention encore n'y a
pas d'âme prend des cinq arrêtés et
prend 1,7
ouais ça passe pas trop peut-être toutes
ces trois du coup et m et du coup il
souffrit quatre essais ça bouffe
taillefer fouet 4 kills et six dames 17
et après m'être le fou en d3 stature est
parti pour quelque chose comme ça avec
les noirs salles us can live
bonsoir à toi
on va voir moi j'espère que je vais
enfin réussir à mettre dedans et à
motiver pour la dernière c'était la
catastrophe
c'est vraiment la catastrophe comment
les jouer j'ai vraiment pas réussi à me
motiver mais du tout quoi
c'est exagéré c'est exagéré d'être aussi
peu motivés a tous joué dans le dernier
mais il part pour faut 4 aussi faut pas
qu'on prenne un trop gros sport histoire
de gagner qui a fait qu'ils aient france
et cambridge où il peut pas juste
prendre des cinq notes maqué avec et b6
encore voilà toujours une quoi aïe aïe
aïe il y en a toujours une
kertész faire [ __ ] en d5 et b 6 pouces
et six essais ce beauf à 8,2 la dame
j'aurais peut-être fait s'assurer cette
partie de ces bouffées de la dame
voulait cases blanches c'est pas parce
que l'acquis et b6 et va être mal pas
tourner vite il va prendre mais bon y'a
pas être mal géré sa va etre tres marcel
est égal et à tours qui prend à 6 mais
bon c'est pas très grave le fou défend
bien et non mais ça va il va normalement
il va tenir là nulle où tout peut
arriver mais c'est pas kata et c'est les
petits derrière il se passe quoi lâcher
les petits voilà on va les voir les
petits lacets disputant à dans la note
mais qu'à une tour de plus quand même
avec à l'endroit de pensée qui va gagner
même si les 1200 enfin à les masquer une
tour ses cadres d'échangés détour rival
écoulé une tour cette septième j'imagine
mais bon ça ça va il le fait de tempo
est à prévoir du tout ça va ils
échangent les tours et enfin je pense
que radhi ceis afghane gagner ça a mis
le holà il a gagné d'ailleurs ça c'est
cool faut pas qu'on se fasse notre mills
enquêter là il est pas mal
ouais il a une tour de plus donc ce 1100
là il devrait gagner vrai ses rangs
derrière ils ont des 700 qui ont qui ont
cartonné
ici les pions ils vont par là par la
presse que non il va se prendre une dame
raft
ah c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
oh là là il va faire un échec ne doit
faire ça il va faire un échec ne doit
faire ça il va perdre c'est sûr qu'il va
perdre oh là là c'est sûr qu'ils
allaient faire ça annonce fait cartonner
ici se passe quoi bon alors ici on est
pas mal avec les noirs ok ces dames de
plus donc là on score ni si on a les
blancs c'est quoi ce bordel
il ya des pièces de partout on est une
pièce de plus l'autre à trois pions il
ya plus de temps ça fait peur mais
peut-être un peu
[Musique]
ces choix mais peut-être il réussit à
faire froid ces trois attaques et le
cavalier et du coup a tapé le fou mais
je sais pas si ça marche ou pas j'en
sais rien moi qui le fais croire b3 qui
est la même idée il n'y a pas d'échec ya
pas tour c'est un loto à quelques
secondes contre attaque le fou là bas
c'est chaud et surfe ou f3 et away
j'aime il rend ses trois mais est-ce que
ça va vraiment changer quelque chose je
sais pas et rien sur france 3 il n'a pas
le temps d'aller bouffer sa mère
c'est chaud fou qui joue un coup là
chapi chapo tu es la bouffe et sa
gestion en bouffer g2 ils jouent la
finale n'est pas facile à jouer cette
finale
allez foulée de l'échec h à roye b 3
aurait organisé les pièces forgées 3 ok
autour d'eux peut-être g5 la rapide
hausse casser cette structure non il ne
fait pas ça pour faire j'ai cinq là un
moment donné mon l'autre mais tours soit
un huitième par baal est un tube ou fait
tu montres leroy fonds séparé ce que je
veux sur leur assure la 8e qui est cette
série chaque échec fous ces trois
bizarre comme décision de façon à tour
f3 quand même nom il aura qui peut
montant h6 rif et n'importe quoi mais ça
j'étais sur dur à jouer à ce niveau-là
contre les points avec une pièce pas
tous les niveaux c'est dur mais à ce
niveau là d'autant plus faux cul
vraiment qu'ils réussissent à ramener
son roi le plus vite possible
heureusement le termine les pions le
plus rangée 5 donc quelque part mes
moyens à faire rage et six sur f5 ya
tout racisme et faut qu'ils le voient je
sens que c'est bien joué du coup il est
mal du coup il aima le schapi chapote
du coup il est mal questionne le f4 ccra
gertie réussi à sacrifier allemand c'est
cadeau mais ça va être dur à réaliser ok
c'est pas un jeu mais un proche des 4 6
3 et 4 on est mal six f4
on aurait pu peut-être échanger des
trucs mais là on est mal parce que les
pions voit avancer et le foie du mal à
connecter peut-être un petit coup de
foudre et 8 pour essayer de rattraper
par l'arrière et fait 3 4
ça pue pour le moment ils bloquent
l'avancée des pions tant bien que mal
j'ai envie de dire mais ils y arrivent
pour le moment
passez pas la dernière partie d'ailleurs
il y en a encore une autre
ce serait bon qu'ils tiennent là nul
c'est dommage c'est une bonne position
car ici organisé s'arrête à téléfoot r
c'est mieux quand même donc à 3,2 trois
fours mais là il ya eu 3 et quand
échangerait finale de tual est foutu ça
c'est mort une biais de faire 3 e 2 s'il
veut espérer survivre mais maintenant il
rage et trois rois g2 et plus le pion là
et c'est fini même elle était dure à
tenir honnêtement
donc on perd 2,12 points alors est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont le score du
premier match il aura fait ce qu'il a pu
après un aller faire un échec
nos échecs mais le plus on va avancer ça
va être mort
je vais m'inscrire pour le bullet allez
faut que j'essaye de secours ont pu
l'être quand même essayer de vous
ramener deux points les mecs
il faut remonter la tour essayer de
machin parce qu'en fait il peut pas il
peut pas faire le pont du sénat tant qu'
il ya le pion aux trois noms qui prend
pire des moments
il prend au pire des moments
quinta catastrophe
catastrophe totale donc allé moi
j'essaye de m'en aller je me chauffe
pour le pour les deux plus ça je me
chauffe pour le 2 + 1 c'est quand même
important
on a quoi on a on a perdu le dernier
match plein qui a qui allaient score 42
24 11 au matin qu'on y est tout est ok
no 20 à 7 points d'avance ok on a marqué
82 points et ils ont marqué 78 ans n'est
pas on est à temps on a great 18 et
après on a perdu 12 en a pas de plus
grand chose hein on est les mitroglou à
82,76 j'arrive plus à compter mais 82-76
caezar et j'arrive plus à compter 82 76
allées mais qu'il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on aille faut qu'on
aille chercher le faut qu'on aille
chercher la victoire là les mecs il faut
qu'on aille faire la différence
il faut qu'on gagne le match ici on n'a
pas le choix les m il faut qu'on gagne à
tout prix
si on gagne pas on perd contre les
polonais on perd contre tout le monde ça
fait chier
donc là les mecs il faut se il faut se
chauffer moi je me motive aussi les mecs
motivé vous tous on se motive à fond et
on va gagner ce match il y en a marre en
2 + 1 allez on y va on le fait les mecs
on le fait chez ses 80 partis qui
avaient bien sûr pas mais bon la
dernière fois que j'ai quand même fait
cinq et demi et le premier match j'ai
fait 5 sur 6 1 là je joue tranquille
aujourd'hui ça me réussit pas mais allez
il faut il faut se motiver moi le
premier
ça va bientôt démarrer là le war courant
accula faut que faut que je me défonce
allez je me chauffe les mecs je le
défonce pour les défonce les mach aller
on les défoncer mais qui en a marre et
en a marre de 0 à l'aller ont leur vie
tous de zéro même si on gagne de
justesse après c'est gagner un mâle est
on est on est plus nombreux que une
nouvelle fois on est mieux classé et on
peut le faire on peut le faire les mecs
on peut le faire
c'est serré où est l'eau au milieu par
contre c'est maïs fait on n'est pas de
franck en fait on n'est pas devant au bo
en réalité allez faut que je joue il
faut que je joue bien je vais pas faire
de grubb je vais faire système de
londres qu'est-ce qui fait vous prendrez
ainsi à vendre que j'aime bien mettre la
dame en d3 on va les jouer la petite
finale on va les jouer la petite finale
qui va bien alors menace vous prend v8
tour prend à cette date en de faire bkc
fait cavaler h5 sur les baies 5 je pense
oui j'ai le temps de faire ça je crois
et je peux jouer je peux jouer ça comme
ça d'après ce que c'est si fou sans le
fou de cases noires je suis pas sûr on
va voir je suis pas sûr que ce soit si
dingue sans le foot cases noires ce que
normalement tu veux pouvoir faire
baisser bcg
franchement moi je vais trois en fait
c'est complètement ridicule je voulais
faire b4 je fais j'ai trois bourses à
blain de mon truc mais c'est passe pas
bien joué fallait faire b4 maintenant
s'ils jouent avec afi 6e 5e jeu pas très
bien
ok ben il veut ouvrir la courbe et est
joué sur cette tour qui est mal placée
c'est pas mal joué si je fais des six
jours et plus de jeu je dois reprendre
une fois je vais faire voir des deux
rois c1
parce qu'en fait je veux pas faire grand
roque parce que je veux laisser ma tour
en en place mais ce que ça va
fonctionner ou pas ce qu'en fait c'est
un peu long mais plan si j'arrête mon x
4 que machin que tout en fait je peux
réussir être pas si mal mais bon je
pense qu'il a le temps de faire f 6 e 5
et ça fait hyper mal tour ici ça fait un
peu mal aussi en fait
je fais rien d'eux
par les joues mieux que moi en fait il
n'ya pas de n'y a pas d'excusés à avoir
ne pas concentrer quoi il joue bien il
joue juste bien il joue juste mieux
tellement apprécié fait nul c'est
tellement petit caleçon qu'on va pas
faire et moi je m'en fous je fais
qu'aller d2
ce fait légèrement chine est en fait ça
je calcule mal mais surtour détroit je
peux faire fout d'eux que je vais
étudier en c3
aimant chaîne
faire ça et sur fouet qu'adulé prendre
le cavalier 5
hayatou prend ici à la fin
ouais c'est foutu
à ces horribles
[Musique]
je peux monter le roi là c'est horrible
c'est horrible déjà 7 pouces et 6 ici à
[Musique]
ses oreilles parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
vu mais ça se goupille bien pour lui
savaient que c'est le truc qui m'énerve
le plus d'affaires
non c'est pas du tout ce que je voulais
jouer
mince j'ai plus de temps c'est beaucoup
plus dur à jeu pour moi ah mince
j'arrive pas à jouer et c'est foutu oh
la la
ah j'étais pas loin j'étais pas loin à
la chance qu'il a eue un truc avec
tomber 3 pouces et 6 il avait pas vu âgé
poids assez âgé poids cg poids c'est les
mecs à sanaa était pas mérité autant les
hôtels étaient mérités de chez méritait
autant ça c'était pas mérité âgé poids
c'est sur celle là
ah je suis écoeuré âgé poids c'est chez
toi c'est là dessus c'est marrant comme
parti mais j'ai poids c'est bon mais
j'ai pas mal joué pour la peine
c'était une meilleure partie ah ouais là
il m'a planté un truc super fort
je sais pas si ça fonctionne vraiment
serais tu qualifies quel point ici
samedi et trois fois f2 d'alger deux cas
et c'est cette 3d 8 qui prend 1,8 d'un
prochain et son cavalier reste enfermé
mais peut-être qu'il a un truc plus fort
ici à la précédente
pour moi c'est une bonne partie il ya
égalité pour le moment c'est bon on a
enfin le score du 1er mai à main sont
démenés là il ya 25 16 pour eux ouais on
se fait défoncer c'est bizarre ce qu on
est plus nombreux on est des plus gros
lots mais on n'y arrive pas à quoi ils
sont trop forts
on se fait vraiment battre derrière
surtout il faut qu'on montre les mecs
allez faut qu'on gagne moi le premier
moyens de jouer un truc mauvais mais
hyper hyper concret c'est bien pour le
bullet ils m'empêchent de roquet du coup
mon roi est un peu en sueur un peu
beaucoup même j'encaisse ça
ouais mais en fait tu pas bien
bon on va voir je crois pas qu'ils aient
de maths pour lui à moins que je rappe
des trucs mais je vois pas de maths en
fait ce que moi je la sda main et machin
jusque là j'ai que tout calculer et là
j'ai pas vu de matt et moi je me lasse
ma tondeuse à non je me rase pas mat je
me lasse perpète seulement façon je fais
un échec
deux échecs trois échecs
j'ai pas le mieux perpète en fait
j'ai pas mieux que perpète les mecs si
je prends cette dame et 8,3 ses sept
cavaliers aussi bon allez je tente aller
en traçant rien pour se marrer 1
qui je prends la viande et 6 ok tout
rage de chaque ces trois dames f3a les
dommages auraient pu lui mettre deux
airs à lui pas eu de bol à la première
mais la dernière on a réussi à conclure
et je crois qu'on gagne le match qu'elle
remonte à da de folie finalement j'ai
réussi à en claquer une
la première mal payé 1 vraiment la
tactique il avait pas vus bon mais ça va
je crois qu'on les a battus on est à 41
42 39 et de face on avait des points
d'avance ils ont été malins on est en
train de perdre
et là je crois qu'on va je crois qu'on
va gagner le match finalement alors
qu'on est passé ouais il utilise le live
qui a gagné ici elle s'écoule c'est cool
c'est cool on les massacre
finalement les mecs on les a massacrés
et à 45,39 on avait on avait en avait
six ou dix points d'avance c'est bon on
les phares si on les farcis les mecs à
c'est la bonne nouvelle
bravo les mecs sains bravo les mecs j'ai
fait un sur six c'était la catastrophe à
la mais bon j'ai gagné au moment où il
le fallait le plus on va dire ça comme
ça
c'est très bien
45 43 ils reviennent un peu mais il
reste il reste très peu de parties en
réalité c'est peut-être même la dernière
ouais c'est peut-être même la dernière
dans tous les cas on aura gagnant plus
de matches on les écrase quoi les amis
[Musique]
ils étaient moins que nous ils ont fait
une stratégie pour avoir des mecs bien
classé mais ils ont perdu ils sont nuls
ils sont nul nul nul et polonais null
null null offensivement nul
stratégiquement nu tactiquement null
null null null
ils ont perdu ils ont perdu contre nous
on joue le titre les amis ils ont été
mauvais ils ont été mauvais laissez la
vérité les amis on joue le titre et des
burgers boom e3 boom nul à l'est des
burgers
mais oui beat'm all tel un grand maître
j'ai gagné j'ai gagné au moment où il
fallait il fallait que j'en gagne une tu
vois je suis muet à la fin non mais
franchement honnêtement les mecs 1 c à
les dames le catal et bein je sais pas
il faut qu'ils puissent pas si facile
encore mais dur de sumud fin pour moi
c'est les premières cadence en fait
tellement dorment samaha sam a endormi
j'ai fait le pré ce crime avant j'étais
un peu j'étais un peu un peu un peu dans
le dur quoi la rejoindre y gagner la
dernière 20 0 sur 6 km sa marraine a
énervé quoi j'aurais fait une une
mazaugues loup quoi à défaut de 8 à
l'érotique le fou à les racheter fouache
sanguine le debout à les tours 3 ça
finit quand je sais pas il veut le faire
de refaire la cadence en 1 mn à 105,0
les tours 3 à lille pousse le plus grave
c'est pas mal allez on voit moi j'aurais
fait toujours 3 quand même mais bon j'ai
un peu court
en fait ils menacent rien c'est horrible
fallait faire tour 3 les amis les amis
des burgers hyper kefu f1 n'en fût f1
des burgers et c'est pas mal il va faire
h1 il a les dames et il menace matin
trois fuites non ils donnent trois
obstacles à haïti fait nul c'est bien
bref si ce poème et adam f 5 tables des
six
or il va la perdre wife 5 monte mais
monde du coup monte monte monte a les
joues bref 5
allez on voit
aa c'est donc j'aurais pu faire bref 5
envoyé dans son adversaire il ajoute
qu'un petit bras passé par anne des
blogueurs c'est bien que t'es sauvé la
nul et on a gagné les amis 46 44 20
voilà les amis première victoire dans
les matchs par communauté les polonais
ils n'ont pas existé les amis on a
dominé tout le match ont mené au début
du match on venait en milieu de match on
a mené à la fin du match on a gagné
aller bravo ils sont en sueur les amis
tous les toute la pologne en sueur les
amis toute la pologne en sueur
on a emporté les amis on l'a remporté et
les amis bon ben bravo à vous c'est qui
les prochains congés cas je crois que
c'est les russes les amis non mais ça va
être chaud c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
vraiment pas tous les polonais histoire
de gagner un match quand même quoi
ou peut-être les turcs chez pas bon les
mecs on se retrouve dans trois quarts
d'heure pour l'aréna à tout